washington c'est un autre aspect de
cette crise a rejeté hier la proposition
de la pologne de mettre ses avions mig
29 à la disposition des états unis pour
ensuite les livrer à l'ukraine afin de
l'aider à faire face à l'invasion russe
jugeant que l'offre était source de
sérieuse préoccupation pour pour l'otan
on va évoquer tout de suite l'aide
militaire à l'ukraine sujet de votre
intervention aujourd'hui armé charrier
bonjour alors c'est un peu complexe vu
d'ici c'est aller en retour il ya une
proposition à la base polonaise pour
aider les ukrainiens on comprend bien
mais quand ça doit se concrétiser c'est
extrêmement compliqué rythme en plus
compliqué finale oui en fait dans
l'histoire c'est visible c'est surtout
ça la question quand on parle d'avion on
parle pas de petites choses discrète ça
se repère un avion les ukrainiens ont
demandé en fait d'avoir des avions parce
qu'ils ont besoin d'avoir une qualité
pour aller taper sur les russes et donc
se battre aussi avec eux on sait que les
ukrainiens pilote de l'armement russe
parce que ils ont tous jour même où
leurs chars sont russes ils sont
toujours eu cette catégorie da alors du
coup il ya la possibilité de leurs
données soient des mig soit des sukhoï
qui est l'armement russe et donc les
pays autour on cela pas nous nous on a
un armement comme les américains qui en
armement occidental donc les polonais
très gentiment on dit écoutez mon
anémique à disposition on vous met les
mises à disposition et puis on verra
avec les américains qu'est-ce qu'on
récupère pour chez nous
donc ensuite ils ont une idée ils ont
dit bon bah puisqu'on peut pas envoyer
nos avions de chez nous on va les
déposer sur une base américaine en
allemagne et puis là les américains vont
se saisir de ces avions et puis ils vont
les emporté en ukraine et la washington
s'étrangle pourquoi parce qu'en droit
international vous avez un énorme
problème c'est à dire que si les
américains prennent les avions et qu'il
les emmène en ukraine d'abord l'avion il
faut bien qu'ils parlent de quelque part
donc le pays dont il part
déclara la guerre puisque ensuite une
fois qu'il arrivera en ukraine les
russes sont en droit de dire bah alors
qu'est ce que c'est que cet élément qui
arrive sur un théâtre de guerre donc les
allemands seraient concernés les
américains seraient concernés qu'ensuite
vous mettez quel pilote vous mettez un
pilote américain qui va se retrouver
l'ukraine est donc dans ces cas là vous
mettez un soldat d'actifs de l'armée
américaine qui va se retrouver sur un
autre de conflit vous faites venir un
pilote ukrainien et dans ces cas là il
va falloir que vous justifier auprès des
russes alors que vous avez dit que
l'otan ne rentre pas dans cette guerre
qu un pilote ukrainien a décollé d'une
base américaine sur un territoire
allemand vous voyez la complexité de la
chose extrêmement complexe quand on veut
concrétiser effectivement ce qui partait
d'une bonne volonté de la part d'eads et
des polonais on aura compris on entend
régulièrement le président volodymyr
zelensky s'adressait aux européens leur
demander d'intervenir livraisons d'armes
notamment qu'est ce qu'on leur propose
nous aujourd'hui jusqu'où on peut les
aider on peut les aider mais on doit les
aider un peu discrètement c'est ce qui
manque en fait satisfait également
impliqué avec les avions c'est pour ça
qu'on peut sourire parce que l'avion
c'est tellement énorme quand on du coup
on comprend tout ce qui se passe
derrière mais en fait tout le
problématique vient marchés d'armement
c'est que vous pouvez faire des à penser
avant la guerre vous pouvez faire des
avancées avant le conflit on se souvient
que par exemple les britanniques avaient
livré des missiles pas très discrètement
d'ailleurs les américains ont livré
beaucoup domicile que ce soit des anti
char parce que c'est l'armement russe où
que ce soit des anti aériens ensuite une
fois que la guerre est déclarée vous ne
pouvez plus passer les frontières et
donc du coup pareil il faut que vous
acheminer quelque chose que vous
arrêtiez à la frontière et puis que vous
ayez derrière des groupes qui viennent à
chercher ce que je vous raconte c'est
tous les films d'espionnage c'est tout
le trafic de la contrebande c'est là
dessus que avec un cynisme fou
aujourd'hui on a du monde qui est en
train de s'enrichir dès qu'on est en
train de parler de ses armements c'est
ça on est en train de parler or
aujourd'hui on a du déclaratif et tous
les pays en fait je vais dire de l'otan
pour quelque part diront que quand même
quelque chose pour l'ukraine ont dit
regardez on achemine alors on va voir
les espagnols qui vont dire on va
cheminer des munitions on va acheminer
des lance-grenades on va acheminer des
lance roquettes bon déjà ça c'est plus
discret ça peut aller dans des plus
petits contenants quand c'est des
missiles c'est plus embêtant mais on se
retrouve avec cette difficulté une fois
qu'on a fait ce déclaratif alors dans
ces cas là l'ukraine a tant que vous le
fassiez et si on arrive à montrer que
telle arme est parti de france d'espagne
de roumanie ou d'ailleurs et qu'elle est
arrivée sur le territoire ukrainien les
russes sont ensuite ils peuvent prendre
le numéro de l'armée remonté tout le
chemin qui a été passée est dit a bien
dans ces cas là on voit bien qu'on a
d'autres pays engrais en guerre contre
nous que l'ukraine donc c'est finalement
en fait cette voie médiatique qui a été
quand même tout à fait bizarre et qui
fait que la france par exemple qui a
indiqué l'armée aujourd'hui est très
très discrète quand on lui pose la
question et dit non nous on s'occupe de
choses mais ça nous regarde voilà